your your very busy guy in Ireland I
know you do television and you've made a
movie between one setting this film
you're best known here for once we've
all seen once right would love once I
thank you very much yes um I I do I
would like to ask you though at once
obviously it's a really um classic
musical and now here you are returning
to the subject of music the subject of
the music industry is what's your
connection to music why why has that
become so dominant and your choices as
writer I guess that I finally sort of
resolved the kind of the part of me I
was in a band when I left school and
I've never quite satelitte singer but I
was the bass player I think every bass
there probably once that a little bit
and I they all become directors yeah it
does quite a few actually
and I was never quite comfortable in in
the band and then I left and I went off
and I got a camcorder and I started
making some stuff in TV in films and I
never got a quite right until until once
in a way I had a TV show which I made
with my brother and a friend of mine in
Dublin and I had a lot of music in it
and it was great and it did very well
for us but you know for me was sort of
like people would give out to me about
having too much music in the film in the
in the TV show that's too much score
going on and I was like you ain't seen
nothing yet I'm gonna my next film is
gonna be wall-to-wall musical and it was
once and I sort of came age and it
seemed to me I sort of satisfied both
the filmmaker and the musician in that
film and again then with with begin
again it sort of I don't know it's
strange it's the sort of a jewel jewel
sort of thing there that I get I get
that sort of because I always watch
movies and I thought that the as a kid I
would watch these fantastic particularly
sort of Golden Age Hollywood films where
the scores were so lush you had Dmitry
Tonkin or friends Waxman burn at him and
these giants of a motion picture scoring
and I always thought it was the director
who wrote those scores when I was a kid
because they were like it's so good and
it's so in touch with what's going on on
screen that's got to be the director
unless it's Charlie Chaplin no that's
exactly yeah and then I I figured that
one and I was like I was are they
commissioned music so and I was
surprised by that and I always found
that to be a little bit sad
strange kind of way and I always thought
that sort of the picture and the music
was always sort of married in an in
several inseparable kind of way and so I
guess in a way coming back to the
musical form I found a way of sort of
childishly putting that back together
again I think a big surprise maybe for
us here in the audience is Keira can
really sing yeah yeah she's she's
terrific in this and grace so just as a
question for a director and maybe
casting what comes first I mean are you
casting her as an actor married casting
her I mean obviously the way you shoot
musicals the performer has to be able to
sing I mean yeah it's naturalistic so to
some degree that's their audition I went
and met Kira in London and I had always
sort of thought it doesn't matter too
much I don't you know I don't it's
acting first in this role for Greta
she's got to be able to act and the
singing can be a little less because
it's not Alan Paige it's not it's not
Judy Garland getting off a bus literally
it's and the character wasn't I mean she
says that line but it's also true of
what I was trying to write which was a
character who wasn't gonna sing gonna
dance she was like a little more quiet
and it was more about the lyrics and
more about the song than the performance
and she was always gonna have this
amazing love of her life played by Adam
as Dave and he's the real performer he's
the natural sort of performer so as long
as she could hold a sort of a baseline
tune as long as it wasn't like oh my god
stop that racket it was okay and we
worked with that and I got a great vote
voice coach from LA Roger love who just
worked with her and explained her voices
come from and had to breathe and we're
you know diaphragm and your muscles and
a lot of its just gym work it's just
training and you know working at those
muscles did the songs also come first
for you I mean in life or in this movie
that the story was first in once I I
kind of knew exactly falling slowly I
was writing around and creating that
sort of scene you know it was very sort
of married that process in this I wrote
the screenplay first and left gaps for
the saunas and I would ring Judd up and
I
sighs I've got this kind of idea for a
song here and if there's a slug it sort
of like eight gaps in the screenplay and
we dropped Tetris like these these these
songs into it so his phone was going off
then to Commission the song sort of
knowing who she was and knowing what
sort of character she was absolutely I
mean well then you have Mark Ruffalo
who's just this exuberant force of
nature Lumbo of the music industry just
it's so comfortable in every single role
I see mmm I'm just shocked it's almost
like he doesn't need the scruffy beard
he doesn't need this I mean he's just
always just everything you're saying
just annoys me more because part of
being a director is that you have
romance with women on set and woo them
with your directorial magic and then
Mark Ruffalo standing next to you and
nobody sees you frankly it's like I was
telling you outside girls would come up
you know like a first ad would come up
to get me to come on - satin I'd be
standing beside mark and she's like oh
hey Mark have you seen John anywhere
mark could be like just here if you like
no no he's not there
mark mark I go ah and I'd actually find
myself sort of like just standing quite
far away from him just in my own little
light you know he's annoyingly
good-looking and he's annoyingly
annoyingly nice and he's just he's
resolved as a person he's of up you know
he's an evolved man which is just
annoying and you just I was just going
home every day looking in the mirror and
going out for it there's no point you
know he's like one of these people who
sees a vision and a shape for things and
an order and you do a very sophisticated
thing when you you add his arrangement
when he's he's hearing her for the first
time and the strings and we hear the
drums and and I thought that was a
really beautiful gesture where did that
idea come from that idea came from you
know the idea that producer is an A&R
man you know hear things and they say
that I'm you always say that you know I
see this or I hear this but literally
there are certain people who almost in a
sort of a synesthetic sort of way will
here are these instruments when they
hear a song when somebody plays in the
song and guitar they it's not that they
hear at meta far could they actually
physically hear strings coming in here
and I've heard that expression and I've
heard of in relation
people like Stevie Wonder who I think
famously like here's how Arrangements in
his head and can't get them out of his
head and it drives him crazy was very
interesting and I thought wouldn't it be
interesting to you know what's the
cinematic version of that cuz hearing it
is one thing and then it was sort of
like why don't we just see what's inside
his head as opposed to just sort of hear
it so there were very few sequences I
mean as a as a musician myself and it's
a fan of music I love movies about
making music and yeah that moment of
creation and you think about scenes and
movies like Amadeus or Hustle & Flow
when you see people in the studio
working and developing something and I
feel like that moment is right up there
well that's the thing I think that films
I think there's that that that idea from
I guess from early movies and I love
montages and movies where it's sort of
you know like in the scythe Parkway
let's have a montage here because we
don't want to see the whole thing happen
and I love those old thirties movies
where Humphrey Bogart says let's one
some questions around town and then it's
a music place and you see people
interviewing and asking people stuff in
a montage and then they get an answer
and but I think for what what sometimes
montages miss or directors miss is that
they they don't have the courage of
their convictions in terms of the idea
that audiences are quite happy to watch
things being made you know the way like
in a painter will paint something in a
movie and it'll sort of it'll dissolve
and the painting is done or something
like this you know the before and after
it's like you missed the best part in
the way process in the way audiences are
quite happy to sit back and I think a
lot of directors can go aboard them but
actually you won't bore them and in fact
with the montage you sort of it's a
little bit patronizing in a way to sort
of and I think that actually more and
more I think maybe it's a technological
thing or it's I think kids are really
fascinated to see how things are made
how was that done I was a song written
that wasn't held and put together I was
a whole dog or a painting painted in a
way I think that's sort of you know if
you look back at the very very early
days of cinema when the camera was first
being cranked up the first thing they
did was just show things happening in
the world train arrives at raymond's
exactly Niagara winner yeah you know
these things and then and then obviously
a change and we started telling stories
and and it's almost like things are
coming fully around again to sort of
putting cameras on things and
and leaving them there and anything's
happened I think it's fascinating yeah